for
a lot of fans don't know behind the
scenes i don't know where you're at with
this situation
but i had a conversation with dame and
him and hopson are back
kosher yeah they're back talking there
might be something
happening between them two um not
necessarily music
but something um which i never thought
would ever happen
yeah me and you i mean obviously you're
really close to the situation but you
know i mean you guys are my guys and
james you know i've had a good
relationship
with dame for a long time and i thought
that that was like
when he called me and told me that they
were called i was like you're for real
the [ __ ] now i had asked him like
so does this mean the gang is getting
back together right
now this was like a month ago and i and
he and he had told me that you and him
might have had like some weird energy
now i don't know you and dame but like
what what is that what is the
by the way shout out to jared jaren for
being one of the best people in the
world
um but what is like your interest in
getting the crew back together per se
you hopson and jaren and maybe
even if it's just a song not even like
funk volume coming back or an album like
just a record
something like that what's your interest
in that um i would be
uh i would be down i'm not going to say
that my interest is crazy high like it's
something that i'm just
extremely looking forward to but i would
like to see it happen
eventually it's crazy because as close
as i was to the situation i disconnected
myself so much
you know when me and dame kind of had
our little falling out and the energy
was kind of weird between
us i completely just kind of detached
myself from all thoughts of
moving forward in any kind of direction
with like funk volume with that old [ __ ]
yeah with the old [ __ ] i was trying to
figure out i kind of felt like it put me
in a funk a little bit because the fans
were kind of like
you know i had never did nothing to have
the fans
you know on my page or coming at me with
so much negative energy this was kind of
this kind of happened after the breakup
so it was kind of odd like i didn't do
nothing wrong yeah it was all kind of
new for me
you know new energy so i had to figure
out how to shake that and like do my own
thing but um
i absolutely don't know the details
about
um game and hop right now like i was
supposed to actually
i was going to get with dame a couple
weeks ago in vegas and we weren't able
to make it happen but
he's probably stuck at a craps table
probably
a man is a gambling man oh yeah he gets
his money you know what i'm saying but
yeah we'll see we'll see um i definitely
think that it's a
i think it's a beautiful thing to see
hop step
into his own you know i know that he's
been doing some soul searching
he's been traveling and uh i really
wanted that for him as a homie
even back when we were on the same label
together so you know if
if he was able to like tap into some
some higher energies to make him you
know see things a little differently
and feel better about himself like i'm
off i'm all about getting around that
type of energy
and you and him had recently kind of if
i correct me if i'm wrong but you and
him had kind of recently
had a a resurgence in your friendship
again
as far as communication and like we did
getting on the same page again like
just kind of communicating like because
i feel like there was so much
man during that time i remember like
that last tour y'all did together
i remember like there was just so much
weird [ __ ] like hops to call it out
crooked eye and all the guys are like
just putting you in jared like yeah
we're over here catching strays
i had heard that you guys had kind of
reconnected recently and like
just kind of i guess
came to a good place more recently is
that's true yeah yeah there were some
things that i didn't know
about the fallout that wasn't made
really clear to me
that um i found out maybe two years
later
i hadn't talked to hopson in like two or
three years or some [ __ ] like that and
then i finally hit him and asked him a
question
and um from there you know i realized
that there was
it was ex some extreme miscommunication
when when funk volume was like falling
apart
so we was able to kind of hash things
out from there
and then um last year
um i did go pop up on him well he
actually popped up on me
and a lambo
yeah i said i'm on my tour bus but my
boy popped up in the lambo so
i was just super proud of him and we was
able to just you know
get on good terms and uh you never know
man you never know the fans might get
something
is it kind of like a gift and a curse
having fans like that
oh for sure because it's like like you
said it's like yo they're hidden like
like i feel like like those kind of fans
like you know shout out to strange music
or like
like those kind of fans are so crazy
yeah i tried to shift away from those
kind of fans actually i kind of let them
uh weary they self out of the dizzy
right
vibes you know if that wasn't what they
was into because it's like i'm not like
uh
i [ __ ] all the other rappers but we [ __ ]
with you you know type of dude
like i don't want those kind of fans i
want fans that are real like
like music enjoy music and know how to
pick the [ __ ] they like and know how to
stay away from the [ __ ] that they don't
like but i i don't want to be a part of
like
i [ __ ] this person [ __ ] this person but
you to go you know what i mean
it was this but then again you can't you
can't control how people
think and you can't control what kind of
fans you have so you got to kind of roll
with the punches it's just a learning
experience